principle number one get stronger and
reverse to the pain because that's
usually the simplest and the least
painful thing you can do it's the full
range of motion that often scares people
principle number two restore and train
full range of motion but at the level
that doesn't hurt you if you have only
those two principles and if you then
worked at it you could probably create a
cool system for just about any area of
the body
dude you are everywhere right now you're
on fire it's a competition between you
and the liver king for who's got the
most exposure on instagram at the moment
hey
i'm i'm lucky man but
not an influencer no not an influencer i
agree and i don't mean to put you in the
the same bucket as the the liver king
although he does do a lot of sled drags
man
i i appreciate it i mean that guy's
reaching a ton of people i don't think i
have as much engagement as him so i'm
honored for the comment but he's got me
beat yeah yeah he does do a lot of sled
drags
very cool
so talk to me about the first major
injury that you had because as far as
i'm aware you had a laundry list of uh
injuries throughout your athletic career
as a youth
yeah um
around age nine i had something where my
knee would kind of
it would pop out of place and sometimes
it wouldn't go back in
and
it was probably 20 years before i like
not quite 20 but almost 20 years later
before i realized a lot of people have
this so i've made videos on this now
probably someone listening to this right
now is like oh my gosh i thought i was
the only person whose knee pops out of
place so
starting at nine i knew my knees were a
little bit shaky compared to other
people and by 12 that was really chronic
pain
maybe around 14 is when doctors thought
i had the first real
uh severe injury to it so 9 12 14
those are dates that come to mind so
definitely not like a normal uh
developing young adult body because my
knees were having injuries and pains
what was the sports that you were
pursuing
just basketball which when you go so
crazy hard after one pursuit probably
just about every sport is gonna have
some kind of overuse injury that if you
that you could just over
overuse drive yourself into a problem
with an area what are the most common
injuries that basketball players get
knees by far
okay why
well we
we not only run a lot but you're running
and then stopping running stopping and
yeah you have that in
football soccer but then we're jumping
thousands of times so you're adding
you're adding the running stopping
cutting
and jumping so it seems to have the
greatest total volume of the stops and
the jump so in terms of the actual
amount like if a if a mathematician just
analyzed how many pounds of force is
going into someone's knees uh you know
basketball players would be putting the
most stress on their knees i guess as
well the shoes and the court is designed
to facilitate that super fast
deceleration
yeah it's made to grip so you can you
can thrash against yourself harder
basically [ __ ] yeah i have a friend ross
in australia with the same age about 34
and he'd played basketball at university
up until 21 and then stopped and i
played cricket at university and then
stopped and both of us decided a couple
of years ago that we were going to
re-take up the sport that had captured
our youth right you know we'd spent 10
years all that we did throughout school
was play this sport uh and the
equivalent thing happened to both of us
i ruptured my achilles and my first game
back and he decided to start playing
hoops two on two i think or three on
three with some friends uh and he uh
tore his acl the first day that he went
back damn and i was like this is such
you know for every single guy or girl
who's done a sporting pursuit throughout
their youth and then thinks ah it'll be
so cool to get back into that a little
bit later on it's like yeah it would be
but condition yourself first
yeah condition yourself and
you know you're 34 um i'm 30. i want to
be playing basketball with my kid he's
one year old so i'm training so that i
can still be super active in my 40s and
not be sidelined not being able to
participate or in pain to do so so
in some ways i could say it's as
important to train for this
now when we're older even if we're not
training for a pro career i would say
it's important if not more important to
be trying to bulletproof our bodies well
that's what you see i think as you get
older right that you realize
increasingly you start training for
longevity you start thinking about i
want to be still crushing it in 20 years
time even if you're 50. you know it it's
not about
the summer shred to look good on the
beach with the boys that you might have
been
aiming for when you were 23 and that uh
i called it the fitness menopause um
that sort of occurs toward the end of
your 20s when you do maybe get an injury
or your recovery takes a bit longer and
you realize actually
my body isn't it's not made of rubber
and magic like it used to be
yep
yeah
if you look at a little kid
so it's never been clear to me how we
bulletproof the body because i have a
one-year-old so he can go into any
position
that adults would look at and it like
hurts to look at
so his the mobility is off the charts
however
he's getting hurt all the time not
within himself against the outside world
because he's weak if he stumbles he
falls he trips he can't so you have
these qualities you have the mobility
and you have the strength
and the way you bulletproof bodies you
train them both in harmony
not separately so the more strength you
can gain through ranges of motion
and working at a pain-free level meaning
a level that your body can probably
tolerate and adapt to rather than too
much
too much force that it hurts like it's a
simple indicator it should feel good
what you're doing
but yeah if you can get the strength and
mobility to have a marriage in training
which has never
there's never been any mainstream system
for that you have yoga one side you have
power lifting for example yoga power
lifting would be like two opposite sides
of the coin and there's both there's
truth to both and if you can get those
to marry together
you might not be the best at yogi might
not be the best at powerlifting
but you could create a far more
resilient body and get freakishly
athletic and by learning from each other
the yogi could be more bulletproof
against the outside world the power
lifter could be more bulletproof within
himself to not injure himself but it's
it's that
it's that realization of
holy crap little kids aren't hurting
within themselves but the outside world
is hurting them now we get older we
don't trip and we don't fall as hard as
we did but we we pull things within our
own body we have non-contact injuries
then what happens once we start tipping
over 40 we start losing both of them we
start losing the mobility and the
strength and then we really are falling
down the stairs and and having
terrible problems
talk to me about that tension between
flexibility or mobility with strength
because
as far as i was aware the more
flexibility that you have the less power
that you're able to put out
what does it mean when you're talking
about training through range strength
through range and and what's the tension
or trade-off that you have there
yeah so
if you just stretch
what signal are you sending to your body
you want to be able to move through that
range of motion but the whole reason for
lifting weights like if you just press
pink dumbbells it doesn't matter what
your intent is you're not going to bench
press 400 pounds it's not going to
happen because you're not giving your
body that that stimulus
so
it's there's unusual exercises but some
of these have been used some of the
stuff i do
that gets people the breakthroughs was
already being used a hundred plus years
ago
and everything's pretty intuitive and
the idea is to
gain strength through
full ranges of motion to gain strength
in areas that we're normally weak or
that we normally don't train what would
be an example of something like that
so the my favorite exercise i use i call
it an atg asked to grasp split squat so
you've been in the gym you've seen
people do split squats you may have seen
people do some astro grass squats you've
probably never walked into a gym and
seen someone do an ass to grass split
squats like i can do a front splits just
off two strength exercises i do a
strength exercise for my hamstring and i
disaster grasp split squat for my hip
flexor and i can do a front splits so
that's an example you can gain
flexibility but i'm only doing so
through through strength exercises
and in an astrograph split squat
which anyone can just search you can
if you watch one of my videos it'll be
hard not to see that exercise i put
endless content on this if someone is
new to my stuff
and
that's going through a full range of
motion on the front leg so that the knee
is going through a full range of motion
the back hip flexors are stretching to
their full range of motion but i'm
trying to get stronger from within those
positions and in the isolated instances
where they analyze what happens when you
actually get stronger through range of
motion you seem to get an exponential
reduction of injury so it's not like
it's not like i think the atg split
squat would make you
twice less likely to be injured because
you're working strength and flexibility
i think it would make you four times
less likely to be injured compared to if
you if your strength you did only
through limited ranges and then you
separately
stretched those same muscles but not
with loads so that's that's the most
classic example from my program
is there any loss of strength what about
the the guys that are concerned that
they're going to lose speed or power by
increasing their flexibility
we have a number of power lifters
breaking their own records on their
squat because most of these guys are
working on mobility in some ways so all
of a sudden now they get to work
mobility and be carving into new muscle
tissue
so like my legs have totally changed
from this stuff coming from being like a
chicken leg guy and now i actually have
leg muscles so we're seeing power
lifters who have stalled and have knee
pain blasting through the knee pain
and hitting new numbers but not from
only doing that from doing power lifting
plus using this as the accessory work so
i still go
i can do all kinds of basketball dunks
now even though i reached age 20 i'd
never been able to grab the rim not even
at one time in my life did i grab the
rim up to age 20. now i'm 30 and i'm
dunking every which way but
that is part of the stimulus that makes
me jump higher is the jumping
it's not like i don't jump at all i i go
i play basketball
but i do this training
plus basketball it's not like a power
lifter wouldn't do their power lifting
this would be my entire system
i think of as
an accessory system for whatever
someone's trying to do so for me i used
it for basketball
well i mean i remember
seeing videos of tom platts doing there
might have been a heel elevated
almost look like [ __ ] squats but like
real narrow
legs together knees touching right so
feet completely side by side with a i'm
pretty sure he had a good amount of
weight on his back and obviously
homeboy's just repping it out like 30
reps deep and all his friends are
screaming in his face in the gym um and
you know he's probably got this the best
legs of all time
yeah
but
there's articles and videos using his
image saying
don't do this you'll tear up your knees
only tom's in his 60s
and can still squat deep with amazing
mobility so he's actually a product
of the work he put in now he was taking
he was in bodybuilding which means he's
he's juicing out of his mind as part of
the sport they all are so he's juicing
out of his mind he started doing this in
his teens and he gradually built up over
decades and he had tremendous attention
to detail on form like what you would
see him do he built that
from decades of mastering his subject
but
what was the product man the guy
bulletproofed his knees and he's still
mobile as heck in his 60s and he
achieved what he was trying to he's
trying to build the best legs in the
world and he and he did he could squat
500 pounds rock bottom for 23 reps he
did one time so
um he was he was able to get
the you know arguably the strongest um
legs through full range of motion you
could argue he has you could argue he
created the most bulletproof knees of
all time
yet people have used his images to scare
people into not training their knees
over their toes
it is a strange one that's the world we
live in so go back to you're 15 years
old you've had this laundry list of
injuries and you're struggling a little
bit how do you go from there to then
whatever within 10 or 15 years being
able to touch the rim
yeah so i was trying everything i would
go to trainers physiotherapists i went
to dozens of specialists for the knees
or trainers and
not all trainers do this but the ones i
went to did and clearly the majority
were telling people don't let your knees
over your toes and this at the time this
made sense when my knees go over my toes
that hurts so avoid that position and
then i saw a quote from
an olympic trainer and it said no no the
athlete whose knee can go farthest and
strongest over the toes has the least
chance of knee injury his name was
charles poliquin and because of what i
had been through i instantly knew that
piece of data was true
now i was a pretty smart kid i wasn't an
idiot so i didn't assume that the that
the way out would be working through
pain
and so my career from that point has
basically been
what clues could i gather from athletes
who do have healthy knees and
bulletproof knees and how do i turn that
into a system that the average person or
the person like me with super fragile
knees who isn't an olympic level athlete
how does mr fragile how does mr old my
nickname in high school was old man i
was made fun of for the lowest lowest
vertical jump on my team now i jump
higher than all the guys i went to high
school with but in high school i had the
lowest vertical jump i was made fun of i
had the slowest sprint time
and i had all kinds of nicknames
harassing me for my lack of knee ability
so
that's what i did from that point if i
hadn't lived through
such crap and been prevented from knees
over toes
then
see this piece of really uh forceful
data of the athlete who's making the
farthest and strongest over the toes but
it gave me such a contrast that i knew
that it was true and then how do i get
there and so i've been able to bridge
that gap now that's that's my career in
a nutshell why do you think it is that
allowing the knee to slide over the toes
other than the fact that people that
have knee pain have knee pain i don't
have knee pain but that's been one of
the cues that i've been given in the
past as well
why is that such a a no-no to many
trainers
because 50 years ago has found that when
your knee goes over your toe there's
more pressure on your knee that's seems
like common sense to me it wasn't found
that it was bad it was found
that's where there's more pressure
now coming later in
every longevity expert knows that the
body needs pressure you actually have to
a sedentary lifestyle doesn't make you
live longer avoiding bending your knees
for example
that's a scientific death wish for your
knee because you're signaling to your
body not even to fully use the joint so
if you're not training with your knees
over your toes through a full range of
motion it means you're not signaling to
your body that you want that area robust
with circulation and strength so you can
actually develop those internal
structures of your needs so for some
people who have never had a problem
i wouldn't tell them to change what
they're doing let's start with all the
fragile people who have been told not to
let their knees over the toes and
let's start with just the lowest
regressions that anyone could do just
for
basic mobility for life like you should
be able to like bend down and play with
your kids you should be able to
even in your case for example
when you restrict the knee over the toe
when you don't let the knee over the toe
you start preventing the soleus muscle
which has proven to be the key for
protecting your achilles so saying no
knees over toes is also a death wish for
the achilles you're saying
i don't want my body i don't want the
tendons and the muscles to develop in
the area that i need to protect
my achilles
so
you choose your heart i mean it's either
going to be
hard now the good thing is i just paved
the way so that people can follow a way
simpler gentler route than there was
before i came onto the scene that's why
i'm knees over toes guy that's why it's
blown up because people can access it
it's not mythical it's not expensive
it's it's simple stuff
that anyone can learn and apply but that
is hard in its own way studying is hard
learning is hard being willing to go
into the gym and do new things being
willing to go into the gym and go
backward when everyone else is going
forward to use a full range of motion
like i said unless you saw someone on my
program you probably have never seen
someone doing an astro grass split squat
and you might get called sus
that's hard
that's hard
but it's pretty cool that we can change
like
now i get to go some some people comment
like boy i'd love to do that
but my buddies in the gym would make fun
of me well let me tell you i'm not
lacking for you know any admiration when
i'm throwing down i'd rather be throwing
down these dunks than hobbling around on
weak knees and getting injured to me
it's a lot cooler and to me it's a lot
cooler to be yourself and to pursue what
you know you want to society sets up
certain structures it doesn't mean
they're right so it's set up certain
structures which have been found to be
incorrect but they were the prevailing
ways at first
now found incorrect found to be
long-term
longevity problem makers and it takes
some serious guts to change a system
once it's established let's sink into
that a little bit i'm fascinated by the
mindset that people need to be able to
continue to do
rehab
uh the basics the boring stuff and this
is coming from my own personal
experience of fighting a bunch of uh
disc bulges from the last few years i've
worked with dr stu mcgill for the last
three and a half years since he came on
the show
and
did me in the corner of a powerlifting
jim doing the big three
and then taking a kettlebell and then
having the other hand up here and you
know walking up and down doing loaded
carries doing weight a carries doing
bottoms up carries and bottoms up press
doing cat cows all this stuff
i've enjoyed
i haven't really enjoyed i haven't
enjoyed being the guy in the corner of
the gym but i have enjoyed the um
lessons that it taught my ego about what
it means to kind of be in that big group
about being able to throw down but
it's not easy you know it's not
tremendously enjoyable to not be able to
if you're doing crossfit or powerlifting
or weightlifting or brazilian jiu-jitsu
or whatever like with the class with
your bros or your friends just doing the
thing talk to me about obviously that's
something that you went through through
your
junior years and then you're now
coaching people to get through that how
do you advise them to deal with the
discomfort of no longer being a part of
the the main throwdown
well the first part of that equation
because i was there and i tried all the
normal rehab stuff you would see
so one reason i fell in love with what i
do now
is
you're active you're getting some of the
hardest workouts of your life
it never quite felt right to me to go to
the gym and not get an incredible
workout so that's what i deliver for
people an incredible workout that also
happens to be rehabbing your body people
come in pro athletes come in get some of
the best workouts often saying that was
the best workout of my life i mean
they're drenched in sweat and their
muscles are pumped in so
most people didn't realize that rehab
can make you sexier that rehab can give
you an amazing workout so that's
that's what i try to do is make it make
rehab sexy and make people realize that
you can and should be getting
incredible workouts and that physical
therapy and exercise
don't have to be two different things
maybe in early stages that's not my role
is not being a doctor so in early stages
if you have an actual surgery or
whatever
that's not my role i was already years
removed from surgeries i had one knee
full of surgeries was so stiff from the
surgeries partially artificial kneecap
my other knee was like loose because i
was diagnosed with tears and that that i
didn't have surgery on
i was already years removed
from gnarly stuff in both knees by the
time i started applying this it's not
like i it's not like i was coming fresh
off a surgery and like now let me try
this this new thing so
i can't tell someone what to do
immediately after an injury and that
would be unethical but for someone who
wants to make their body
more resilient and change their
longevity
you can and should go to the gym and get
incredible workouts and that's why
people are falling in love with this
that's why it's
it's not staying a boring physical
therapy thing it's it's becoming a
really bona fide system of actually
being able to exercise your body i go
get my cardio
and strength for my whole body and i
have my six pack and i power up my legs
for sports what i do
now that i'm super healthy is no
different than what i did to get healthy
it's the same exact program my program's
almost identical to what it was like
five years ago because the more i find
out the very thing that can bulletproof
me and rehabilitate something
what if i continue that and no one's
ever tried that that's what hasn't been
tried is the idea of physical therapy
and exercise physical therapy and
strength training staying as one and
that's what we're seeing the results is
we're seeing 30 year olds all over the
place are now dunking and having the
mobility of younger people and sprinting
faster and
so
that i think that's why it's caught on
is because it turns into something that
people enjoy if if a workout program or
a diet is not something that becomes
something you enjoy i think it'll stay a
fad and it'll fall off quickly and we're
seeing the opposite there's over 700
coaches now being certified in my
program so people are people are
starting to realize
that physical therapy
and exercise can work together i would
agree i think that you're definitely
talking about playing on hard mode if
you're doing something that you don't
enjoy as opposed to playing on easy mode
if it's a diet or a training plan that
you do
but i would also say that you know
in any one gym there's maybe
one person that's going to be doing your
program so there's still you know you're
still the guy or the girl in the corner
you're still the person that's got to
generate your own motivation you're
still watching the people that maybe you
used to train with or you want to train
with or you could train with if only you
were a bit more healthy doing the thing
and the music's blaring and there's
high-fiving talk to me about that that's
the pain that i'm talking about
i i look at these things and i'm
grateful as heck what i went through and
being the guy because at some point i
was there wasn't even one other person
in the gym doing this stuff so
um
being the knees over toes guy for
example that was like i chose man i
don't give a [ __ ] about ben patrick i
care about helping people screw my name
i didn't even like social media but i
said i'm gonna sacrifice
and be knees over toes guy to educate
people on that myth
so
going through the things i went through
being the only guy in the gym doing
something backward of everyone else it
made me mentally like on a different
level from what i was before i'm over
470 days without a cheat meal or any
entertainment not a single sports game
not a tv show not a movie i'll break on
either of those when my kid asked me to
he's one year old
so i've i've blown up on social media
and in the trainer world by saying
hey
why not outwork everyone in the industry
literally every single person sacrifice
more than anyone else anyone can go a
day without a cheat meal but going 470
days you have to be like another level
mentally same with not doing a tv show
why because i'm a great dad and i spend
a ton of time with my kid but i want to
also work on my business so every half
hour tv show that's half an hour away
that i could be getting more successful
that my mind could be operating more
creatively but i think there's no way
i could have gotten to these mental
toughness levels this these abilities to
control myself without every time being
the guy walking backward with a sled
because every time you do that you're
making your body do something that
you know is right for you
but you're having to control your body
to do it it's not that you can't just go
with the flow and do the easy thing
so i'm as grateful for the mental
aspects of this
as the physical from going in being the
guy walking backward with the sled it's
now given me a cheat code at life that i
feel like i'm like distant
from all the sheep and it's like i feel
like i could pick anything and be
successful at it now because i could
determine and get myself to do the
things that are right rather than just
being shoved along with the current so a
lot of people have noticed this effect
now that the more they walk backward
with a sled the more they start to
be the person they want to be in life as
crazy as that sounds
i think that there's something
there's something that you learn it's a
combination of swallowing your ego and
having to generate your own motivation
to do something boring and repetitive
and hard you know i
yeah i honestly wouldn't surprise me if
i've spent a thousand hours in the big
three positions over the last four years
or whatever it really wouldn't surprise
me uh what do you think that did for you
mentally
it was it was weird man because
throughout most of my twenties i was
always in shape uh
doing commercial male modeling and then
got toward the end of my 20s and was
like jacked out of my mind and in really
really good condition and then had you
know two disc bulges in the space of six
months and
then everything that i was relying on it
made me wonder
what does it mean to not be
you know one of the leanest or most
muscular guys in the gym and i i
realized that a lot of my identity and a
lot of my self-worth and a lot of my
confidence had become wrapped up in the
aesthetic of how i was and this is
common right this is why young guys go
to the gym this is a big bit of you know
like the simply shredded
bodybuilding.com forum era gym culture
like that was what a lot of young guys
transcended their
uh insecurities their lack of confidence
around women their desire to feel
powerful and in control and capable and
responsible and like a man they wanted
that they wanted that and going to the
gym gave them a sense first that they
had mastery over something in their life
so if
their girlfriend split up with them or
if their most recent university
assignment went to [ __ ] or if they got
the the job wasn't happy or they were
living in a place that they didn't like
they knew that they'd got themselves one
step closer toward their body so that
was the first thing and all of the other
bits and pieces right
but you roll that forward and
i had to sort of question look what does
it mean to be
me now what does it mean because i can't
be
i can't rely on my physique for my
self-worth because if i want to do what
i need to do which is what stu said and
take a very sort of long slow
iterative process on building this up
over time
uh i'm i'm gonna lose i'm gonna become
uh smaller
fatter
uh less muscular and and and slower up
until the point at which i can then
begin to start to add some of this stuff
back in and that was hard man like that
was you know it's a difficult period uh
you're just not as resilient
but that being said
it's
it's the same as having anything taken
away that when you realize that you were
relying on it it was buttressing your
life right i
enjoyed going sober i know that you're a
sobriety uh user for uh like a
productivity tool and i loved doing that
because i realized that it was
buttressing my self-confidence it was
butchering my desire um to be outgoing
and charismatic on a night out because i
didn't have that i didn't i never had to
develop those skills
in the same ways i'd never had to
develop genuine confidence or a sense of
self-worth around other people aside
from being in really really good shape
because as soon as i lost that i was
like oh okay well i have two choices i
can either have no
self-confidence or self-worth or
whatever
or i can be forced to develop it because
i no longer have that support structure
in place it was very interesting very
very interesting transition
yeah i mean that's awesome at the end of
the day uh
what's going on
what's going on up here in our head is
going to be
more important that's what's going on in
our body so it seems like
it seems like that's a
common theme and
that we can take something that seems
like a downfall and maybe actually be
grateful for it in some strange way so
that was one of the things that held me
through too was just getting a different
viewpoint on
what i was grateful for and so
when i was trying to get myself out of
pain i would go do my leg days and i
would be just grateful that i had legs
no joke like i would be like
this is amazing that i just that i get
to go to the gym and even try to work on
this so
it's hard to say looking back
um
what exact factors led to what but
changing my mindset
being really grateful for stuff like to
this day like i'm just
whether i live five pounds more or not
like i'm just grateful that i can go to
the gym and like do my workouts i'm
grateful that i can go tomorrow i get to
go play basketball with my friends like
i'm not nervous about whether i'll make
a shot or not like i'm just grateful to
go do that
so
i think that could be really valuable
advice for someone as well
and i had to note this down for myself
i find for myself my ideas can get
scattered i have to have pretty simple
note structure in my phone that i remind
myself of the really key things that i'm
working at in my life so
that really helped me to remember you
know you look at your schedule and it's
leg day and just to remind myself to be
grateful for that and i think that
started to change some things and it
seemed like for you you
um when it took away certain things
maybe that just powered you up to get
more skilled so like i now have new
skills on how to train the body because
of what was taken away from me so
there's a lot of interesting stuff to it
unfortunately i'm not i'm not jordan
peterson so he would probably figure out
what the hell i'm talking about a lot
better but maybe one day i'll i'll
figure out how to rationalize it all i
have a friend george who uh once a month
he has a reminder on his phone when he
wakes up to spend five minutes lying in
bed imagining what it would be like to
not have any legs and i told me this
story
and it was made me laugh and but it
reminds me kind of of what you're
talking about he said really really
imagine what it would be like
to
to lose both of your legs in some
accident and think about how grateful
you are for the fact that that hasn't
happened and he used this
use this example um the comparison game
that we play online a lot of the time
we're seeing the worst of our own life
compared with the best of everybody
else's so he while he was still in the
uk
he would go to a hospital to the what's
the is it palliative care is that the
very is that the old people
i don't know okay well whatever the
whatever the end of life sort of care is
you know where you've got the older
people in there and stuff maybe they've
not got so long to live and he would go
and i think he volunteered to just help
out doing whatever he did and he said
dude i come out of there and the
contrast effect the difference between
instagram best of my multi-millionaire
friend's life living on a yacht versus
mine working a job in manchester
and then i flip that and it's me 20
something year old guy
with all of his life ahead of him and
the liberty to do whatever he wants
against some
you know 72 year old dude that's got
pancreatic cancer and is about to leave
a widow behind
that's huge
and i think we have to give ourselves
credit for this which is that these
best dubs are forced in on us all over
the place so
we can
people complain about people complaining
i see posts complaining about people
complaining like should i make a maybe i
should make a post complaining about the
people complaining about people
complaining but
um
look
we're
it's natural these things can happen to
all of us because it's shoved in on us
at every turn making us think that we
shouldn't be happy if we don't have a
yacht so we're complaining about this
and that but it's it is a different age
and more
of these kind of false senses of
happiness are pushed in on us at all
turns so i try to just surround my to me
it comes down to who i surround myself
with and that goes both in person
and that goes online so even identifying
people there are certain people i
i tend to follow
online that when i watch that i feel a
lot better about myself
so like jordan peterson an example when
i see a video from him i tend to feel
better about myself and more motivated
for life and then there's certain people
that
even if they're respected in the
training industry or whatever
and i see them on the boat or what i
don't you know i could just get that
icky feeling man i i know and this is
this is something i unfollow the icky
feeling yeah and i follow the people who
are going to make me feel
more grateful
yeah and you're right that i mean that's
such a
it's more difficult in the real world if
you've got a job you can't you sadly
can't unfollow that colleague that's a
dick you know they're there in the
meeting every day they kind of remind
you of the thing that triggers you i
spent uh douglas murray was on the show
yesterday and i
adore that man i spent
pretty much all of yesterday afternoon
he did rogan in the morning and then
came to my show and then we went for
dinner straight to dinner on the night
time wow and dude he
he just he's so
like positive and and and
i walk away from every interaction just
feeling like my capacity to do stuff and
he's not an inspirational speaker right
the guy talks on culture walls and
writes for the spectator in the new york
post and [ __ ] um but i leave every
single interaction with him feeling like
the world's at my feet and feeling like
i can go and do whatever i want and it's
like that's the world that you should be
trying to create with with the people
that are around you and
yeah especially if you're going through
hardship especially if you're struggling
you know injury is a good example
because we have injury occurs physically
but it also happens at different other
things you know we have a relationship
injury or we have the loss of a family
member or we have financial injury you
know some sort of setback that we need
to deal with
and everyone needs a douglas murray man
everyone needs that person that they can
rely on and i feel really bad
for people who don't have that community
uh because you know for a big chunk of
time
i didn't really feel like i had someone
that
or a big community of people i was
heavily relying on my business partner i
was heavily relying on a couple of other
people in the uk
and then when you finally get a just a
little bit more of a social circle like
that
you see why network effects are so
important and how you can impact your
life like that
so yeah man i i really hope that
the
if there are people that are struggling
with injuries and stuff like physical
injuries like look
get your mind right find some people
that can support you and know that it's
going to do you well for the rest of
your life not only in terms of your body
but also in terms of your mindset that
was what i took away from that period
yeah and and
maybe that bad thing happening to you
maybe
you'll
maybe that'll end up being
maybe there'll be a silver lining to it
that you're able to actually become
greater because of what happened
that's just how i look at things now
like
your airbnb is canceled
awesome can't wait to see the next one
that i find and be going man thank god
they canceled that other one it doesn't
mean it always happens like that but um
it really can
so
yeah i think
fitness that's just one area of life i
don't take fitness too seriously
you might think i'm all into fitness
because that's my job fitness is just
one part of life family can have
setbacks just as you said family finance
fitness there's all kinds of areas we
could be having setbacks and in a
natural lifestyle we would be what we'd
be kind of
living as communities
uh we'd have close family around us we'd
have close friends around us we would be
out in the fresh air we would be
active we would be eating only
organic foods so all these things that
we now try to put in
um
those would have just been baselines for
living so it's very easy to say
man why are we all complaining when we
have such incredible technology at our
fingertips well
i'm a mathematics guy like that i think
of things in terms of math and the math
is that more people are struggling and
depressed and having mental health
problems so if that's the case
where have we deviated something must be
wrong i'm not just gonna blame
the human race for what's going there
must be something there that's actually
deviated and
and i you know i think you're on to it
with um
just how how easily we can be comparing
some other lives to what we're actually
going through that stuff that you've
just mentioned there that more uh primal
approach to
fitness and health sounds a lot like
what andrew huberman pushes forward i
know that you guys have been spending a
good bit of time together recently what
have you learned from your time with
andrew what stuff have you taken away
from his work and the time that you've
spent together
man
um
first off he's just a great guy and so
it's pretty cool when you see someone
online
and then when you meet him in person you
know like
this is just a
great person like he want he genuinely
wants to help people and he's super
interested and passionate in what he's
doing and i think that can really help
us as well and the modern education
system the way it's set up like
how many of us end up winding up doing
something it's not like
we're incredibly passionate about that
so seeing how passionate he is
having something that you look forward
to that you're really into
i can see that as a big component of
happiness like deep down he's a
he's a really happy person
compared to the average person that i
meet he's also very very interested and
passionate about what he's doing he has
something to look forward to and so
in the time we had together um
getting out
taking walks in the morning before you
have your cup of coffee i mean there's
too much to count but
really basic things that someone could
start doing to construct habits that
could lead to better things so it would
be if someone's just hearing of andrew
huberman it'd be better to to really
dive into his content but
what have you applied you've applied
you've applied the morning walk before
coffee sunlight in the eyes yeah any
other stuff yep
any other stuff from him yeah i mean i
would just say i would just say
a bit of renewed uh looking at my life
differently of my happiness is not just
a thing right now like um
that will just stay the same forever
that you you
you make your happiness and part of that
is really having things that you're
interested in looking forward to and
chomping at creatively and business-wise
so
we just enjoyed our time together i
wasn't like i wasn't like grilling him i
try to
i try to be like you know uh pretty
gentle kill people and
i like to observe
and then i usually take away something
pretty big based on what i observe
um so
that's that's as far with with huberman
but we're buddies and we stay in touch
and i'm sure i'll learn a lot more you
can also observe the fact that he is
jacked out of his mind you don't see
this it doesn't come across on a
on his podcast but i bumped into him in
kuya which is the um sauna and ice bath
place that i love going to in austin um
yep have you been
no but i was right next to there at on
it's right next to me yeah it's
literally next door dude when you're in
town i got it i have to take you i have
to take you to kuya
and uh so the door the door opens and
it's late on an evening time and the
front doors
face the
west right so the sun's setting
uh and
the sun sort of bursts in through the
doors and it opens up and it's just this
[ __ ] gorilla stood like silhouetted
from behind he comes in he's like hey
we've been talking on instagram i was
like hey man how are you doing you know
you shake someone's hand and you do that
handshake where you shake the hand and
then you you put your other hand on the
floor dude it was like hitting the
outside of a shed like what the [ __ ]
andrew what are you built of what's
what's wrong with you uh but yeah he's
he's jacked out of his mind he's really
really uh nice dude he's coming on the
show i can't wait to bring him on and
that's huge yeah he's he's a big one
we're gonna do something special for it
as well i think that's awesome but
yeah i just couldn't believe how
how big he is it really doesn't
uh show on camera
he really takes care of himself and i
think that's one of the things that
makes him great is that you have you
have the mind you have the body and he's
working both angles and he's he's really
living it he's not just sitting off
detached out of shape out of touch so i
mean
yeah he's he's jacked skin in the game i
think
yeah
skin in the game exactly all right so
getting back to the uh knees over toe
stuff we've spoken about the fact that
strength through range uh muscular the
ability to do muscular contraction
through bigger ranges so that's not just
the um sort of physical way that the
muscles move or the functional way they
move but also the movement engrams right
it's what the brain knows that it's able
to do and how it's able to deploy and
contract that muscle in those positions
what else is it that you're getting it's
not just muscles and movement right
there must be some i'm going to get i i
would have thought the first thing would
have been like ligaments or tendons or
synovial fluid or stuff like that try
what's happening now
all of those were correct meaning you
could get into some angles and and pump
up muscles and that would be good like
you are you should be getting
circulation and strengthening to your
muscles
but when you don't put it in these
angles of pressure and when you don't
fully bend a joint taking that for
example fully bending a joint signals to
your body that you're maximally using
the joint so you get more of the
synovial fluid which carries the
nutrients to the joint now if you did
that with an amount of load or an angle
that caused you pain
that wouldn't mean that it wouldn't have
some constructive mechanism
but how are you going to be able to
recover from that so the idea is to find
not alter the movements not run away
from the movements find the level of
full use
so
not avoiding full use of the joint what
is the level of full use the amount of
load of full use
that you could do for as a terrible
example some of the exercises if you see
it well if you imagined uh walking
backward under water or bending your
knees under water there would be less
pressure there so essentially you're
you're honestly finding the level of
pressure that there isn't pain we need
the pressure to build up we need the
pressure through a full bend we need to
pressure knees over toes among other
areas the ankles the front of the shin
the hamstrings we need these pressures
to build things up
but we may have gotten to a point in
life where we're very weak and tender in
some of these angles and so fully
avoiding it that becomes hugely
problematic finding the level you can do
has taken a lot of work with a lot of
people to find the right angles how do
we do that how do we get into these
angles
and then building up from there to what
the people with healthy knees can do
take me through a couple of your highest
return
exercises for knees and then a couple
for shoulders as well because i know
that you've got a big a a big set of
work around shoulder health too
good so
dragging a sled backward would be the
simplest way to get a knee workout
started forward is also great on the
sled i use a mixture but we do
even more backward than forward most of
us haven't worked backward when we work
backward you take your step back you're
actually working your knees over your
toes so you're not just using a such a
heavy weight that you're leaning your
body back if you look from a side angle
every step your knee should actually be
over your toes so that's the gentlest
way to start building up strength with
your knees over your toes you're
building strength cardio circulation
you're strengthening through your foot
what are the typical leg day exercises
squat deadlift leg press leg extension
did you ever work your foot not once did
your foot actually bend and load
so
this is building from the ground up for
your knees getting that position knees
over toes dragging a sled backward then
getting into full ranges of motion on a
split squat would hit it from a totally
different angle
so you pump up you get circulation with
the sled
then you start to work on your full
range of motion build strength from
there and then a couple classic
finishers would be actually lifting
weights you can do a bodyweight version
against the wall but tibialis raise
t-i-b-i-a-l-i-s
raise and you'll see endless videos on
this now since we've started
popularizing this and now there's tons
of people making equipment like
you couldn't even buy
a device to load free weights and
strengthen your tibialis muscles didn't
exist it was no longer being sold
now rogue fitness is selling a tibialis
bar they're being sold everywhere and it
started with an australian friend of
mine reaching out saying what piece of
equipment needs to exist that doesn't
and they fell out of style they actually
came about like 50 years ago
but they they just didn't get into a
style a guy named bob gaida who is one
of the early bodybuilders before
steroids was around and then right when
steroids came in
bob worked at the ymca getting kids off
the off the streets off drugs then i see
people shooting up steroids so he's kind
of an interesting guy
he wasn't business-minded he was
apparently terrible at business so you
couldn't buy these things to strengthen
your shins now you can buy them
everywhere
that's the muscle that's closest right
up underneath the kneecap
and then also doing doing hamstring work
and hamstring curl machines are common
and are great back extension machines
what's less common is what's called like
a nordic bench so that's essentially
doing a body weight hamstring curl and
the reason that is so related to the
knee is that as you lower down now
you're just directly resisting your knee
your knees ability to not be pried apart
so for example an athlete if they
couldn't resist their knee being pried
apart
they're let they're
at more risk of a ligament tear so
that's like a really simple bullet
proofer but even for some older people
getting that into into these regressed
everything has like
a regression so you can start somewhere
see where you're at train there get a
great workout recover come back get a
little bit stronger so
talk to me just before you go on talk to
me about um either duration intensity
loading repetition distance just so
we've got uh sled
um
an example
go 10 minutes straight backwards sled at
whatever level feels good for you drag a
sled backward for 10 minutes
then do five sets of 10 reps
on this full range of motion split squat
at the lowest level that you have to get
into by elevating the front foot or
assisting yourself just getting into
these mobile stretched out positions but
gradually loading and then then do
three sets of 20 reps on that tibialis
muscle which you can start against the
wall you'll be you'll be scorching
you'll be on fire many of us who are
fragile realize oh my gosh we never
strength trained these baseline
preventers of achilles and knee injuries
and then a simple three sets of 10 just
controlling down on a nordic or if you
don't if you don't have something to set
up for that a hamstring curl you know
just get some work in there behind the
knee so what did we do we we got
stronger we put energy on getting better
backward of what hurts our knees with
the sled backward full range of motion
strengthening below the knee
strengthening behind the knee that's all
pretty common sense like okay like
circ you know get circulation get
strengthening for the knees strengthen
the knee itself like the these you know
these top muscles these top thigh
muscles and and particularly when you go
to a full range of motion you start to
train that that vastus medialis that
teardrop shaped muscle that's closer to
the knee so what did we do in the
workout we trained the muscles that are
closest to the knee
and we got stronger at all the areas
closest to the knee
one of the things to make it unfancy
sounding sorry to spoil
the party yeah yeah just
improved our pain-free ability
everywhere around our knees
one of the words that you used earlier
on was um
pain and avoiding pain and not pushing
yourself too hard into that but
presumably especially if someone maybe
hasn't done this before or perhaps
they've got a history of knee injury
there's going to be a modicum of
discomfort here
um what's the cues that you give people
to know when
pain is okay pain's not okay
the best is just to start at the lowest
level
even if it's like super easy and then
and then do more sets it's not like
we're just doing one set we're doing
we're usually on a main exercise doing
uh it could be as low as three but as
much as 10 sets like you have time
there's what's the rush you got this
workout you got next workout um and and
also with the sled the sled is so cool
that it gives you something that you can
you can gradually work really hard at
even if you're someone who normally
has that tenderness and has that pain so
the sled is like the lube the backward
sled is the lube that helps all this
other stuff occur then start at the
lowest level feel the muscles working
see maybe if you can go to the next
level see how that feels but never hit
where you try a level that's harder and
maybe that gives you some discomfort
just go back to the previous level and
keep pumping out reps got you right
shoulders
shoulders there would be three
big ones
um that are essentially all the opposite
of the motions that hurt the shoulder so
usually someone with shoulder pain
if they
get their their knee up on a bench and
if they if they rotate the muscle the
external rotator muscles and i have
videos of these
uh
using a dumbbell usually they'll be
really weak compared to like the front
of the chest muscles
and so even without even having to dig
into the front of your shoulder without
even having to to do anything risky you
can start by strengthening your external
rotation you can start to strengthen the
lower trap muscles which are like in the
middle of your back where you're you're
on a you get on a back extension machine
your body's at 45 degrees arms are
straight
so and and you can do a power raise
where you're even easiest is to start
with the cable so you're seeing how much
weight can you strengthen behind your
shoulder blades so those those big three
set a really good foundation like your
shoulders in trouble if
if all the muscles behind them are very
weak compared to the front but at the
same time as doing that we are restoring
full range of motion of actually
pressing and using our shoulders so like
like i i take bars behind my neck and
and i press like imagine you're setting
up for a squat and the bar's on your
back
how pain-free and strong someone is from
that position of pressing the bar from
behind their neck is the easiest
predictor of shoulder problems and
imagine if you just took something super
light and you gradually built that up so
even with the shoulders
and i rarely talk about the shoulders
because it's going to take the same
process as talking about the knees the
back the shoulders how you bulletproof
parts of your body is going to follow
these same common denominators so the
first three exercises that i described
if you watch a baseball pitcher that's
the sport where they're tearing up their
shoulders the most
kids are having like an epidemic of
shoulder surgeries in america trying to
throw baseballs harder it's like the
knees for baseball so knees in
basketball shoulders for baseball we
have a youth epidemic of surgeries like
that's not fun that's gnarly stuff
and so far beyond a reasonable doubt
these kids in their teens who are having
shoulder surgeries
they are just not strong enough in
reverse of throwing a baseball no
different than the basketball player
who's pounding into the knees is not
strong enough in reverse if you are
strong enough in reverse of emotion that
could injure you you now have a math
equation so i can land from a dunk on
one leg but could i land from a
skyscraper no i died
so it's just a math equation of how much
i can handle if you run and then you
have to slow down and stop
for someone with really bad knees that
would hurt they wouldn't be able to stop
themselves
so
with the shoulder it's the same thing
built on a foundation of how strong are
you in reverse of the motion that hurts
and then to get the joint to get the
synovial fluid and for the joint itself
to build up it then needs full ranges of
motion a simple one for someone would be
rehabilitating a full range of motion
push-ups so using rings or even hands on
cement blocks and not stopping a push-up
halfway nothing not that there's
anything
wrong with any traditional exercises but
if you
if you couldn't do a push-up with the
full range of motion and if you never
trained through a full range of motion
you wouldn't be giving your shoulders as
much synovial fluid to heal so it's the
exact same principle as the knees so you
would basically say principle number one
get stronger and reverse to the pain
because that's usually the simplest and
the least painful thing you can do it's
the full range of motion that often
scares people so number principle number
one get is get stronger in reverse of
what hurts principle number two
restore and train full range of motion
but at the level that doesn't hurt you
if you have only those two principles
and you had no background in exercise
you could probably create if you then
worked at it you could probably create a
cool system for just about any area of
the body if you get stronger and reverse
of what hurts and you restore full range
of motion and train strength through a
full range of motion but the level
doesn't hurt so now i my shoulders
i i add weight around my waist and i do
dips where like to me it's not a dip if
my if my elbow isn't above my shoulder
so i'm i'm fully stretching in and
pressing out um
so i use full range of motion on
exercises and i'm strong in the reverse
of these common pains and it's like a
cheat code like it feels surreal to do
some of these exercises that growing up
like it would have hurt me to do this
stuff and now i can do stuff with my
back my shoulders that
really would have hurt me when i was
younger and now it's like so easy and
i'll be able to train the rest of my
life and i'll have stronger joints i'll
have more actual tendon and ligament
tissue i'll have stronger tendons and
ligaments and more strength in the
muscles around those joints
so it's it's pretty neat but
it's so cool i'm not a podcast guy i'll
be honest i don't like doing podcasts
but this was worth it because you made
me think about it and those two
principles is really
that's the best way to describe it
i love it man i'm glad i'm glad to have
helped inspire you with that one thing i
noticed you haven't mentioned here which
i often see people talk about in regards
to shoulder health is hanging what's
your thoughts on hanging
well just today i had uh 20 kilos
roughly 44 pounds around my waist and
i'm doing full range of motion chin ups
so
i'm a big fan of going through a full
range of motion that chin up uh i go all
the way down to a full hang position and
then i explode up so uh that works for
me if someone wanted to do so what what
sorry what we're talking about here is
the equivalent when i'm saying hanging
whatever it is i know you're talking
about actually just hanging passively
right but what would that would be the
equivalent of you know sitting in a
passive yin yoga style
whatever glute stretch or some [ __ ] as
opposed to doing your asthma
yeah yep yep yeah ito portal i believe i
mean i haven't met ido but i believe
people have told me that you sit like 10
minutes in a squat like the goal is to
be able to sit down in a squat the way
people do in in every native culture
they they rest in a squat and you build
up to where you can rest in a squat for
10 minutes and that's helped a lot a lot
of people have gotten out of knee pain
from doing that now in my case i found
better results from doing actual
motion-based strength training that
worked better for me and even if someone
is doing my motion-based strength
training through full range of motion
i'm not going to stop you if you want to
do some extra hanging yes i just can't
make i can't get myself to go do
something
that i i am the ego lifter i'm the
skinny kid with bad knees with terrible
form rounding his back on a deadlift to
get a pr and i i am the ego lifter so
i i need it to be enjoyable you'll never
catch me enough i never foam roll i
don't go in ice baths i don't i don't do
anything for recovery and i don't hang
even though i'm not against it but i go
full range of motion
on my chin ups trying to get stronger i
want to challenge i i was doing it
why not
you know like you're going to do the
chin ups in any case
why not bother to do it and this is what
you said earlier on about you maybe need
to take a few steps back first because
you're used to doing
four by ten
at with 20 kilo weight belt around your
weight but you're only taking your arm
to there right you're not going to full
extension so you go oh so you're telling
me now that i'm going to have to drop
down to only five kilos and go well yeah
okay you are but then once you're able
to build yourself back up toward that 15
to 20 range think about how much more
activation how much more range you're
moving through much more health yeah
dude
as a simple um
tool to be used
thinking about what are the stretches
that you're doing how can you make those
more active how can you try and find a
way to move through that plane of motion
so that you know it's not dangerous you
take it one step at a time you realize
that fitness is a lifelong pursuit not a
pursuit that needs to
be completed and mastered within this
very one session um
you mentioned as well just before about
um backs
and
lower backs is something that i have
far too much familiarity with
i see that you're a fan of jefferson
curls and other stuff what have you
found when it comes to bulletproofing
lower backs what have you found that's
that's effective for you
what seems to be the foundation of the
lower back in getting someone out of
pain
is the ass to grasp full range of motion
split squat because
where have we deviated like
why are people having so much back
problems i refuse to believe that like
whoops we screwed up designing the human
body and all eighty percent of the human
race is going to have back problems
it's the same with the knees we see that
in areas where people live more
naturally they have less of these
problems so i would have to assume that
the amount of sitting we do in chairs
our hip flexors get very shortened
and it's not just a theory people who
get good at this astrograph split squat
remark all the time they're just having
there's thousands of people doing this
and there's so much less back problems
with people whose hip flexors are
lengthened out and strong so already
we're strengthening
in reverse
of all the excess sitting so i sit like
a normal guy i'm not the guy with a
fancy uh chair or something or i i don't
sit on that but you're standing now
you're standing at the moment to do the
podcast forrest set this up for me i
didn't i didn't even choose standing
podcast standing podcast the hack man
i'm telling you people that want to
start doing a podcast oh dude
your energy's better you're able to move
more you can shift from side to side i
can't i do this sit down podcast now and
i'm like oh god just i feel so
constricted i don't like it so he's your
man's got it right he's giving you one
of the hacks good job brother
um
so
so it starts right there be strong and
mobile in reverse of the excess sitting
and then from there
your back itself
has
there's one level of back strength is
the ability to
resist being crunched over like imagine
uh imagine you have a dead lift and you
go to an amount of weight that you can't
hold your back straight and it and it
rounds like the weight is breaking the
strength of your back muscles
that is a form of back strength but you
also have some areas into your upper
back muscles that help hold things up so
meaning even into what's called the
thoracic spine for someone who's not
into exercise now we're talking about
higher up to the back and it's found
that people with a more with less
thoracic spine ability
those people have more chance of lower
back surgeries and shoulder surgeries so
you have you have your whole spine
and part of it is being able to resist
the
the pressures and injuries that could
come in on your back
but another part would be your ability
when you are lengthened out so if you
wound up in a position in life
where you bent over and now your back
was in a rounded position
it's found that people who can go into
that position better have less back
injuries so what i do is i use
very light amounts like i think of
training the rounded position of the
back as a quality that i want to be
really good at but really gentle with
and then i think about the ability to
resist rounding as a quality that i want
to be really strong in
with built on that foundation of my hips
being set properly from the astrograph
split squat that my hip flexors are
really lengthened out and strong through
stretched positions so
i i think
different joints are are different
and then you have the spine which is
different than like a knee joint this
spine is a unique beast all of its own
yeah yeah but i think it would still
wind up
rationalizing pretty similar like
like
actually it does rationalize similar
which is okay you want to be you want to
be able to resist your back rounding but
you also want to be able to round your
back just like you want your you want to
be strong in reverse of the knee pain
but you also want to be able to be
strong if your knee is fully bent so
it's not like you're avoiding the fully
so the the fully bent position in the
knee would be the same reason that i
intentionally train my back in a rounded
position and
man i haven't had a back tweak in like
many years and i used to have to
go to a chiropractor or feel like crap
for some weeks or not be able to lift or
not be able to you know struggle to play
basketball feeling my back just i
thought that was normal because so many
people i knew had back problems so
yes the majority is knee success stories
that people send me every day like a
flood
but many people are having these same
realizations because my program's always
just been a full body program it's not
just a knee program it's always been a
just a full body exercise program
but using those concepts be able be able
to resist
that position where we get hurt but also
be training the position that would be
the tougher position
at a gentler level basically
thinking about the type a
uh go get a gym guy and this was another
mentality that i had to let go of you go
from being someone who's chasing down
your aesthetic goals by pushing hard in
the gym by training frequently maybe you
know six days a week with active
recovery maybe double sessions
what
how much
is too much in regards to training
frequency when it comes to your stuff is
there a point of diminishing returns is
there a point where you can do too much
i think there kind of is for anything
because you have the recovery process
you also have the mental side of it of
getting
burnt out tired not having the energy to
focus so
i actually try to program it as
conservatively as possible because we
know the body is gonna the body has the
ability to heal and adapt and get
stronger so i try to almost program like
like
not overdoing things um
so
the average person i think
um
like what i currently have with my
weight program is we do legs twice a
week so monday thursdays legs tuesday
fridays upper body we sled
all four sessions at the start because
it just helps get that circulation keeps
our cardio in gets our feet stronger so
we sled all four sessions to start but
then monday thursday likes tuesday
friday's upper body so
that's a very general schedule could
someone go six days sure but the people
out there winning training six days it
doesn't mean they wouldn't make gains on
four days um do you find if someone was
to do
one upper and one lower session per week
um are they still going to make
progress are they going to be able to
just mitigate
damage
they would still make progress so the
person just doing say they're just
supplementing one of my sessions a week
for the legs let's say they're still
going to make progress they're still
going to make gains
most people like to exercise more often
so most people want to exercise their
lower and upper bodies at least twice a
week and and even with those wednesday
and weekends off tons of the people
doing the program go work on extra weak
links from the program and like they
can't help it they want to be in the gym
so
it's your life it's not four days is not
special even one day of doing of like
working i have
i have different areas that we're trying
to master different movements we're
trying to master
heck if you went one day a week
and worked on some of those
one day a week is enough to cause
changes for sure
ben patrick ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the program and
all the stuff that you do where should
they go
atg
that's my business it stands for
athletic truth group
also asta grass
exactly i really liked the word ass to
grass and so i wanted to make an acronym
with astro grass so athletic truth group
is the business name and atg
onlinecoaching.com is the website
awesome knees over toes guy everywhere
else instagram youtube blah blah blah
it'll all be linked in the show notes
below anyway ben dude i i really
appreciate you my coach larry that i'm
working with at the moment he has very
much taught me about the line between
recovery
physical therapy
rehab
training conditioning strength all just
being one spectrum continuum matrix that
you can move through and i think you
know increasingly i'm seeing people like
yourself like larry
treating things like that and i i you
know i really hope that this continues
you worked great man and i
longmate continue
man really appreciate you thank you so
much for having me on
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you